[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
yeah
it's felony Friday
Senator Bob Menendez come on down
while you join former president Donald
Trump
Congressman George Santos Anthony
divulder whatever his name is and soon
soon to be charged possibly hopefully
maybe crossing our fingers
Justice clear clearance because he's on
clearance he's for sale Thomas
holy [__] are you kidding me
oh man what a morning this morning uh
the the doj and the sdny announcing this
morning they are indicting Democratic
senator Robert Bob
um Menendez and his wife in three other
New Jersey businessmen now here's the
story
had to confirm this
but Bob Menendez here's his committee
assignments okay if you're unaware he's
on the finance committee he's a senior
member he's a senior member of the
Banking Committee it's a good thing he
knows a lot about gold bars apparently
and cash so he's kind of starting his
own bank
of bribery it seems not only that the
guy the guy is the chairman of the
Foreign Relations Committee chairman
that's what I said chairman
of the Foreign Relations Committee
rut row
um the reason why this is so important
is because
Bob Menendez Senator well soon to be
probably former uh Senator I mean he
really only has two choices here really
if you think about it he either can
resign or he can go to Schumer and it
resign all his seats on his or resign
all his committee assignments and ask
Schumer for the Senate to open up a
senate ethics investigation immediately
there's a really is only two choices
um
today
and more than likely his best choice is
to go ahead and resign
and then try to fight this in court if
you're not aware Bob Menendez has been
in this position before where he's been
criminally indicted and Bob Menendez
remained the United States senator of
New Jersey while he was being indicted
now before
and I really I've been looking into the
new indictment this morning so I had I
didn't have enough time to go back and
refresh myself on the last Bob Menendez
indictment you know here's here's the
good news about this is that we have a
system in this country
that is designed
to
prosecute political corruption if it
needs to now is it perfect in that form
not exactly it's not exactly perfect in
that form but it does do that now there
has been some hiccups along the way when
I first read this headline this morning
my reaction was ah [__] that [__]
let him remain a United States Senator
we're George Santos this guy all day
long we'll protect this guy because
bribery really really that's illegal uh
and the reason why I say that is because
the Supreme Court really undercut and
the doj's ability to to prosecute
political bribery cases if you refer
back to uh Governor McDonald he was a
republican governor of Virginia the guy
was taken like he was getting like
[__] sports cars and they were and it
was a real rich guy that was giving them
all kinds of lavish gifts jewelry
dresses uh all all kinds of vacations
sounds familiar Clarence Thomas who is
for sale apparently we're gonna get to
that story too I promise you on felony
Friday here we're gonna get to all the
corruption oh my God Jesus the [__]
swamp is deep in DC good Lord
um but back to Bob Menendez my first
reaction was [__] that [__] we're gonna
George Santos this guy we're gonna be
like [__] that prove it prove it [__]
uh oh not not so much the case because
the evidence that is in the unsealed
indictment is stacked against Bob
Menendez and really honestly it is the
type of evidence that is stacked against
a criminal indictment like Trump has in
DC and and in Miami and really the the
state indictment he has against him for
the RICO charges in Georgia
like the unsealed indictment has enough
evidence to go whoa you're [__]
and Bob Menendez is completely [__]
here
um he is in a conspiracy now his wife is
on this indictment and again I'm not an
attorney and I was talking about this
this morning in the um in the pre-show
we have a pre-show on Discord if you're
a member of the patreon you can go and
we have a lot of people show up this
morning more and more people are coming
every Monday and Friday for the pre-hour
we do a one hour discussion before the
show on Monday and Friday
this is a very interesting discussion
this morning about this uh Bob Menendez
case as it unfolded this morning because
the press conference went on and I I
listened to part of it and re-listened
to some of it before coming on the air
um of the the the announcement and the
unsealing
of the indictment now him and his wife
are both on this so they're they can't
the state can't really get them to turn
on each other if that makes sense
because their husband and wife but
there's also three New Jersey
businessmen that are also wrapped up in
this uh political bribery case not only
that they found listen to this
apparently they have found
uh 480 000 in cash a lot of it's stuffed
in envelopes and hidden in clothes and
closets and a safe so they just weren't
like
you know collecting up cash and they
didn't know where to put it like they're
hiding it who the [__] hides 480 000 in
the coat pockets of their suits in their
closet come on now
and so 480 000 were discovered in their
home
um the problem here with this is that
apparently this is the reporting
happening this morning some of the
envelopes
contain the fingerprints and DNA of the
co-defendants making the alleged bribe
so these three businessmen in New Jersey
who were paying Senator Bob Menendez
four of these bribes their DNA ended up
on the money whoops also there's a
hundred thousand dollars in gold bars
my god
oh [__] man
well
you know the good part about our system
is that
it is capable of Prosecuting political
crimes like Prosecuting Trump's
political crimes in that he tried to
commit a coup uh in his political crimes
where he's committing obstruction of
justice and and espionage
to some degree uh breaking the Espionage
Act
right
when he stole our documents and he
claims they're his and they're not
really his they he invokes the
presidential records act which is not
even with the president direct act says
um George Santos being charged with
felonies and the um in in in a district
in New York not the southern district of
York but Bob Menendez Senator Bob
Menendez is now indicted in the southern
district of New York which is probably
the worst place in the country you
really want to be indicted
um other than in a special counsel like
Jack Smith so
um it is felony Friday here on the Tony
Michaels podcast so don't forget to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
you're not going to want to miss a
single episode of this and I'm sure I'm
sure that here's the gonna be the
difference between
um Democrat Senator Bob Menendez
actually getting indicted him and his
wife and his three co-conspirators here
here's gonna be a lot of the differences
number one
um there's gonna be a loud cry that hey
you're a [__] criminal you definitely
do not need me on this committee which
is the Foreign Relations Committee
definitely not mean the chairman
um the financing and Banking Committee
say you don't need to be on those and
you probably should resign if nothing
else call for an Ethics investigation
into yourself at a bare minimum now I
believe that Bob Menendez uh is probably
going to make his way to a microphone uh
sometime this afternoon if not over the
weekend and resign his seat as a senator
this is much uh higher level crimes and
much more evidence in the unsealed
indictment that was in his last
indictment that he now to be fair he
went to a jury trial on his last
indictment
and he won he got acquitted he won he
walked out he was free man you know and
that's just how Justice Works whether
it's the two-tier working for the upper
echelon like Bob Menendez or Donald
Trump or not that's you have to call
that Justice like you you have to follow
that rule of law
um just like we have to be honest with
ourselves here it seems like Bob
Menendez is a corrupt son of a [__]
and he needs he needs to not be anywhere
near
um our most sacred part of our
institutions of democracy
he does not need to have committee
assignments he does not need to really
have a seat on the United States Senate
uh now I'm I'm of the belief innocent
until proven guilty but
holy [__] Bobby
holy [__]
um so that's the the story here and
we're gonna play a couple Clips uh of
the press conference where they they
unsealed an indicted Senator Obama then
this now I want to go to the Clarence
Thomas story because baby
I was gonna run with the Tucker Carlson
story today to be quite honest with you
did you hear this Tucker Carlson is
apparently going to put his his show on
Russian TV or some kind of Russian um
YouTube channel or some [__] I guess
they're gonna dub over Tucker Carlson
and Russian
I don't know if they're gonna get like a
a Russian
uh you know
like a Tucker Carlson you know
impersonator who's speaking in Russian
to dub over him but apparently Dr
Carlson is going to be doing a show on
Russian TV which shouldn't be surprising
to anyone right I mean that's not I mean
just as much as it's surprising that
Clarence Thomas is taking political
bribes
that's the shitty part here right like
we're like wait a second so Senator Bob
Menendez is easily indicted they unseal
this thing everyone in the country is
going wow you corrupt son of a [__] but
Clarence clearance because he's on
clearance he's for sale
you know I think I think he officially
changed his name to clearance not
Clarence clearance he's he's for sale
Clarence Thomas
um
is apparently paling around with not
just the Koch brothers and the Coke the
Coke fund
but he's being brought to retreats
so that people can like pitch their
Supreme Court case to him or some [__]
like Jesus [__] Christ what
and we're and this morning so this
morning uh Bob Menendez
the senator from New Jersey is indicted
on political bribery and Corruption but
Justice Thomas still is not hmm
feels like there is two tears of Justice
not gonna lie not gonna lie feels like
there aren't two tiers of Justice here
um especially when you consider the fact
that Maga loses their mind
When Donald Trump is has 91 counts
against him some of them felony counts
against the United States of America now
speaking of maca and the criminal
faction of the swamp in DC rather it be
the Democratic senator Bob Menendez
rather be the former president Donald
Trump or it be Congressman George
Anthony devolder Santos or it shall be
maybe future indict indictee
uh Justice Clarence Thomas
I believe this whole
the judicial system is weaponized
against Republicans this kind of trash
now right
am I right this is kind of trash now
can we can we can we move on pants that
that somehow
Joe badden is weaponizing
the Joe Biden is weaponizing the justice
department against Republicans and
Donald Trump to make sure they don't
want to get the [__] out of here with
this nonsense
if this morning this indictment and the
evidence stacked against Senator
Menendez in this indictment is it proof
that this is not weaponized
then then you [__] do not have enough
brain cells to to manage to muster
together to figure out any kind of
logical thing I I
and it's not surprising because they're
gonna keep this up
they're gonna keep it up they're gonna
be like oh well uh Bob Menendez is a
sacrificial lamb that kind of [__]
that's what they're gonna say they're
gonna be saying it on if they're not
saying it already
everywhere on the internet that Bob
Menendez is a sacrificial lamb that they
they made sure that they weaponized the
government against him is to show to
prove that it wasn't weaponized but
don't believe him because it actually is
don't believe what your eyes tell you in
your ears hear you
you know believe the opposite of what
appears to be the actual easy truth to
know
is that the Department of Justice is
going to seek out crime wherever crime
they can prove and indict the crime that
they can right
but it does it does start to undermine
their narrative
and that is key here and that is really
how we can
um use our voices and our microphones
because I I just have one microphone you
guys have tens of thousands of
microphones
um you you may not broadcast yours to as
many people but you have more
microphones than I ever dream of having
okay
so use your platform that's important is
to push this narrative that no it's not
weaponized if they're if they're going
after
a Democrat who is the chairman of the
Foreign Relations Committee this isn't
like some [__] freshman senator from
some you know
little state that no one's heard of this
is Senator Bob Menendez the chairman of
the Foreign Relations Committee
using his his knowledge of foreign
relations and taking bribes in payments
of cash and gold
to influence certain decisions about
Egypt apparently
so listen
Bob Menendez might be a good fighter in
the Democratic cause but he is a corrupt
criminal it appears
very loudly and proudly it appears he's
a corrupt Criminal
so it's okay for us to look at Bob
Menendez and say that's enough sir
that's enough
um but again
will the Republicans do the same thing
for George Santos no
for Donald Trump no
will they do the same thing for the
bribes that Clarence Thomas has taken
no
they will not
they're not going to do that
they will not they have no principle
none
um
be sure and Bet On It
now
when you look at the political landscape
and who is the affiliate vote right
because we were talking about this this
morning in the
in the pre-show as well on Discord if
and if you remember a patreon uh you can
you you if you're the 20 two or higher
you can actually get access to that um
that chat room that we have an hour
before the show so if you're interested
in that go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels or just go to the Tony
michaels.com and check out the patreon
there and if you're having trouble just
message and we'll get someone to help
and get you where you need to be
but here's the thing we were talking
about affiliation and I talk about the
affiliate vote a lot
um on the show here and how it came up
this morning is that I posted we posted
skip uh over there in Discord
he cut a video a clip and we posted on
YouTube where Ryan was talking about
there's there's not both sides of
democracy there's only one side of
democracy you're there for democracy or
you're against democracy
and the comments of the [__]
brainwashed delusional fragile white
males was incredible on this video
and every one of them every single one
of them was we're not a democracy work
we're public
we're a republic we're not at a mark
don't you know we're a constitutional
republic course they need to get a
[__] dictionary and look up what the
word democracy means and what a
democracy is and what a republic or a
constitutional republic is like they
need to go look up the definitions of
words and that might be a lot easier for
them to understand
why a republic our constitutional
republic in this example is a form of
democracy but
you know the real thing here is that
they're terrified of democracy
because they really truly believe that
it will it will rid them of their white
privilege
period
because it was all it was all white
dudes in the comments because they had
you know they had
they're
they're avatars they're all white dudes
all of them
but
um and someone brought up in the
pre-show the idea of the Republican
constitutional Republican democracy that
that might be I think it was skip that
brought up that that was part of the
affiliation you know that's the part of
the affiliate mindset right that hey uh
I'm a republican so it's a republic
right I'm not a Democrat so it's not a
democracy
right
like that's part of their affiliation
but they're going to do the same thing
the same thing
with these charges
or or with the non-charges which I think
there needs to be charges against uh
justice Thomas I mean if we're gonna
charge
if we're gonna charge
bomb Menendez for using for selling his
influence with cash and gold
what in the [__] are we doing
not investigating and charging and
indicting Thomas
for his [__] his his bribery and his
trading of luxury gifts
for his influence because that is the
story this morning folks and Ken Burns
you guys know the uh the documentary
filmmaker and he does a lot of PBS he's
done a lot of great documentaries
and he's ramped up in this because I
Ken Burns apparently took a picture at
one of these [__] Retreats where
where Thomas Justice Thomas was given
access to these people who wanted to
bring court cases to the Supreme Court
um so that they could get favorable
treatment
Ken Burns is standing there in the
picture I'll show it to you here in a
little bit don't worry when we come back
from the break I'll show you clips from
the press conference I'm going to show
you the the pictures
of Ken Burns Clarence Thomas and a coke
brother
but apparently the Koch brothers were
having
little Retreats and inviting Thomas so
that they could you know
you're a hash out what cases and how the
decisions were gonna how in the [__] is
this not bribery and Corruption the same
type of bribery and Corruption that is
using to sell Power for gold and cash
luxury gifts come on man
come on man
so in this morning you know a lot of
people are gonna feel like you know
they're beaten up
by a Democratic senator from New Jersey
a senior senator uh from New Jersey who
has a very important chairmanship or
well did this morning he won't buy this
afternoon
if Chuck Schumer has not already removed
him from his chairmanship of the Foreign
Relations Committee now that's a little
more complicated than him resigning
based on the Senate rules of how they
would replace Menendez as the chairman
but I'm sure we could get there pretty
easy you know what I mean
you know what I mean
um so stick around we're gonna we're
gonna come back I wanna do a little bit
of promotion here
um I'm sorry we we gotta promote the
show here and we gotta promote the
things that we're doing here so you guys
know exactly what we're doing now first
off I want to thank you guys again for
going and um subscribing to the library
of democracies YouTube channel
um it's I it's incredible I think
there's almost up to 1200 by now
um so it's really incredible that you
guys went over there I'm gonna put the
link again in the chat box here uh so
you guys can go
and you guys can
you guys can go follow the library of
democracy it's going to be very
important there's more and more videos
going to come up on that channel every
single week there's already I think a
half a dozen videos over there on ballot
pedia to teach you guys how to kind of
navigate through it
um and you guys are going to be able to
make suggestions and all kinds of great
stuff
um so go follow the library of democracy
on YouTube I really appreciate you
throwing your support behind the library
democracy it's an expansion of the Round
Table of democracy you know we were
doing the round table discussions and
we're still going to have those but
we're just going to do them over on the
library of democracy's Channel we felt
like it needed an upgrade and we felt
like it needed its own channel for that
type of content so goat goat right now
if you can go if you haven't subscribed
already to the library of democracy
YouTube channel it's going to be very
important
um that information to you not just to
you but the people around you who want
to engage in your democracy and learning
how how easy it is to find some of the
the resources that are already out there
because the resources already exist we
just want a place where we can glue them
together for you to use and engage in
your democracy so it's super important
the other thing too if you want to get
in on the Discord conversation
here's the Discord I'll put that in the
um
in the chat right now uh that they're on
the live show chat right now but again
if you want to get in on the morning the
early mornings on Monday and Friday is
when I do the early morning show it's an
hour before the show starts and I did it
almost up to the very moment that we
came live here
um so if you want to get into that go uh
join the Discord and also go to
patreon.com
or just go to thetonymichaels.com here
it is the Tony michaels.com hit
subscribe at the top you can find all
you know what I didn't refresh this
let's there we go
so today's episode's at the very top I
sent out a notification to all the
people subscribed so you guys have the
link there uh if you want to buy me a
shot for the weekend and support the
show it's right there you can also send
me a venmo super chat today and tell me
how good I'm doing or how bad I'm doing
either way
um or if you if you got if you got a
story you want to talk about send me a
venmo Super Chat the button is right
there and then if you want to join the
patreon and join in on the conversation
just join the 20 tier or higher on
patreon and you'll have access uh if you
got to use the same email to do the
Discord and the patreon but you'll have
automatic access every Monday and Friday
to that pre-show hour I also want to
thank everyone who has signed up for uh
consideration to be moderators that form
is right here it's still open you guys
can still sign up for consideration
um we are going to be working our way
through
those uh forms that you filled out over
the next month or two and so if you get
messages from us it's because we've
gotten to yours uh and you fit the
description of where we need moderators
and when we need moderators
um so but if you want to be considered
to be a Monterey go there also I want to
thank everyone who renewed their
subscription uh with twitch super
important and just go to twitch.tv Tony
Michaels if you have an Amazon Prime
account you can link it to your Twitch
account
and you can give us that one free
subscription that you get on your Twitch
account with Amazon gaming and it gives
us a few bucks every month but you have
to renew it every month so everyone who
went and renewed yesterday thank you
very much for subscribing and renewing
uh your subscription on Twitch through
your Amazon Prime account the directions
are right here on the Tony michaels.com
you just hit right here link Amazon and
twitch those are the directions to
actually make that happen so I
appreciate all your guys to support
whether you're buying merch if you want
to buy merch the merch stores are here I
appreciate you supporting the library
democracy Gabe Sanchez Gabe Sanchez is
supposed to be joining us for bonehead
of the week at the second hour today but
right now I gotta take a break when we
come back I'm going to show you some of
these clips from the Menendez indictment
press conference and this picture of Ken
Burns with the Justice Thomas and the
Koch brother don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around through the break if you
guys want to hit a pardon blanket
um make sure you send the link to
make sure you send the link to Senator
Bob Menendez from New Jersey he may
[__] need a pardons you just go to I
am Gabe sanchez.com that's right I am
Gabe sanchez.com you can gift Senator
Bob Menendez a pardon blanket
Biden will pardon Senator Menendez you
think he will or his wife
maybe the three businessmen I don't I
don't know
I don't know I don't know maybe he will
maybe he will uh well let's let's do
this let's go to the let's go to the
press conference that the FDNY held this
morning for the uh Bob Menendez
indictment let's listen to what they
charged him with and some of the
evidence that they have let's go through
it
the indictment alleges that between 2018
and 2022
Senator Menendez the senior U.S senator
from New Jersey and the chairman of the
Senate Foreign Relations Committee
and his wife Nadine Menendez
engaged in a corrupt relationship with
Hana Uribe and Davies
the indictment alleges that through that
relationship
the senator and his wife accepted
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
bribes in exchange for Senator Menendez
using his power and influence to protect
and to enrich those businessmen
and to benefit the government of Egypt
the indictment alleges that Hana Uribe
and Davies provided bribes in the form
of cash
gold
home mortgage payments a low show or a
no-show job for Nadine Menendez
a Mercedes-Benz and other things of
value to the senator and his wife
now constituent service is part of any
legislative okay so again they're
alleging these gifts and we're given as
political bribes
what's the difference is you know just
for manga
just for Republicans who love who love
Justice Thomas
and his little traitor Q Anon Live Genie
right what in the world is the
difference between receiving luxury
trips and vacations and accommodation
somewhere and receiving a Mercedes-Benz
what's the difference I mean I I'm I'm
just asking questions right
I'm just asking questions okay well
let's continue and see what else they
got on Senator Bob Menendez uh and his
corruption it's Leader's job Senator
Menendez is no different
and as we explain in the indictment
there are things that Senator Menendez
says he can do for his constituents and
things that he says he cannot do for his
constituents
he put it all on his Senate website
so for instance
it says he cannot compel an agency to
act in someone's favor
it says he cannot influence matters
involving a private business
it says he cannot get involved in
criminal matters or cases period
but we allege that behind the scenes
Senator Menendez was doing those things
for certain people
the people who were bribing him and his
wife
and let me say a little bit more you
know and I I just I just want to point
this out too I mean I mean you know I'm
I'm trying not to do the what about ISM
but I really am trying to do it
what in the [__] is the difference
between Bob Menendez selling his
political power to whomever business
person in New Jersey would want it to
have an outcome that they want using his
power that he says he doesn't have and
Clarence Thomas showing up
at some Retreat where he is where he is
showered with gifts from the Koch
brothers
to make sure that he's standing in front
of people that need a certain outcome on
a case
in the Supreme Court I mean I you know I
maybe I'm off my rocker here right
and I'm I'm saying it sounds like
Senator Bob Menendez is is [__]
I I would imagine that the sdny did a
lot of their homework especially if the
case is true that they found DNA on the
gold and the envelopes of cash think
about this oh my God
so not only do they find the [__] the
the money and the gold they found DNA of
the of the co-conspirator the
businessman in New Jersey Jesus second
Christ all right well let's see if they
get to that or about the conduct that's
alleged in the indictment
the indictment alleges that Senator
Menendez took several actions as part of
this corrupt relationship
first the indictment alleges that
Senator Menendez used his power and
influence including his leadership role
on the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee to benefit the government of
Egypt in various ways
among other actions Senator Menendez
allegedly provided sensitive non-public
U.S government information to Egyptian
officials and otherwise took steps to
secretly Aid the government of Egypt
okay so let's go
again I hate to do the whole what about
ISM thing but ah God damn I just I'm
gonna do it
so
you're trying to influence other
countries and other in other countries
foreign countries are trying to
influence us and you're trading away
money for influence
it feels like to me it feels like to me
that there was a government official who
was related by marriage to the former
president of the United States
are one of them
um and it feels like they received a big
cash amount from a foreign entity
it just it feels like it feels like to
me
that that what about ISM should be
pointed out as well here in this case
I'm just you know gonna go out on a limb
the felony limb here and the bribery
limb here and the foreign bribery limb
here and just say there's probably a a
two a two billion dollar reason why we
would want to have a little bit of what
about ISM on this I don't know we also
allege that Senator Menendez improperly
pressured a senior official at the U.S
department of Agriculture to protect a
lucrative Monopoly that the government
of Egypt had awarded to Hana
a lucrative Monopoly that Hana then used
to fund certain bride payments
second
the indictment alleges that Senator
Menendez used his power and influence to
try to disrupt a criminal investigation
and prosecution undertaken by the New
Jersey attorney general's office related
to an associate and a relative of Uribe
third the indictment alleges that
Senator Menendez used his power and
influence to try to disrupt a federal
prosecution of Davies in the district of
New Jersey in two ways
first by seeking to install a United
States Attorney who he thought
could be influenced with respect to
Davies and second by trying to influence
that office to act favorably in Davie's
case
and as we allege in the indictment the
senator agreed to do these things and
use his power in this way because Hana
was paying bribes
because your rebate was paying bribes
and because Davies was paying bribes
fortunately the public officials the
senator sought to influence did not Bend
to the pressure
that's a good thing
now as part of this investigation
special agents with the FBI executed
search warrants on the residents and
safe deposit box of Senator Menendez and
Nadine Menendez in New Jersey whoa whoa
whoa wait a second you're telling me
that the Department of Justice if they
go to a judge and they have they have
evidence of crime being committed that
they can receive a search warrant
for for a sitting politician in
Washington D.C that's something that is
possible and oh my God as a result if
there's indictments that it's not
political because they're a Democrat
come on now again it feels like to me
that Senator Bob Menendez here is
completely screwed and he's been
indicted before for corruption it is
obvious here with the evidence that is
stacked against him not just with the
three businessmen in New Jersey and the
Egyptian government but also him trying
to [__] bribe a U.S attorney
can you imagine the nuts on this guy
holy [__]
I mean I'm serious Bob Menendez must
need a wheelbarrow to haul around them
nuts
this guy went to a United States
Attorney
and and trying to and tried to tried to
influence an investigation
oh boy oh baby that's crazy
um I I got an announcement here that
doesn't have to do with the news but we
got a birthday in the Discord chat
um it looks like Texas
[Music]
Texas
happy birthday to you happy birthday
60th birthday so everyone
um go over to Discord and
give a happy birthday to Texas
all right let's get back to the um
the news at hand here let's listen to
what else they have to say
when they got there they discovered
approximately five hundred thousand
dollars of cash stuffed into envelopes
and closets oh God damn some of the cash
was stuffed in the Senator's jacket
pockets oh some of the cash some of the
envelopes of cash contained Davey's
fingerprints baby's DNA
oh oh you [__] you you
[__] you oh my God so listen
wait a second see you're telling me
um and you know again I I said this in
the first three minutes are you telling
me
that
Bob Menendez took bribes and then cap it
in the [__] envelopes that they gave
it to him in
[Laughter]
Bobby Bobby Robert Robert dude
come on man
come on you can't you gotta look
If You're Gonna Take the Money and
they're gonna give you the money
in envelopes and [__] you're gonna
You're Gonna Wanna change the envelope
and a bare minimum
and the last place you want to leave 480
000 is the inside jacket pocket that you
were wearing
when you took the bribe what in the
actual [__] is going on at the Menendez
ass huh do they not take [__] to the dry
cleaner
dude I mean Jesus Christ man
[Laughter]
oh Bobby you are [__] my friend you
are so [__] let's continue at all
agents also discovered a lot of gold
that was provided by Davies and Hana
and the FBI of course found the
Mercedes-Benz that Uribe had provided
them
the items that that behind covered are
discussed in the indictment which
[Music]
government business dealings bribing
United States attorneys whoo sounds like
to me
I'm just gonna go on a limb here and say
that um oh Robbie Menendez is absolutely
100 percent [__] [__] [__] he is
definitely not gonna get out
of this indictment I just don't see
um with the evidence that is so far
stacked against him that he is going to
receive a jury poll that is going to
allow him to walk away from this um my
guess is my guess is by this afternoon
and he'll resign his seat as United
States senator now because of the
evidence stacked against him and the
evidence wasn't as stacked against him
in his first case that is obvious
because he was acquitted on those
charges by a jury of his peers
um but again this morning with this
press conference and this unsealing this
indictment when you have
um clear-cut evidence of bribery it's
going to be very very very difficult to
walk away from this conspiracy case and
that's that's one thing that is
glaringly obvious or maybe not so
obvious and with this case is not it's
not just him and his wife that are
indicted but the three businessmen in
New Jersey that are indicted in this
case which makes it a conspiracy which
means that the government is really
gonna Really Gonna dig in on the top of
the conspiracy which is Bob Menendez and
the reason why is because without Bob
Menendez being the senator and being the
chairman of the Foreign Relations
Committee none of this bribery would
have been possible
um so
shame on shame on Bob Menendez shame on
his wife for thinking that this type of
political corruption was okay because he
clearly thought that this was okay
otherwise he wouldn't have went to
United States Attorney
and then posting on your website the
exact opposite of what you're actually
doing come on man
um what happens to his Senate scene
someone asked well I believe because
he's the senior senator of New Jersey I
believe when he resigns uh the governor
of New Jersey is a Democrat and I
believe the New Jersey state laws that
the Democratic governor would select a
interim uh Senator until they would
trigger a special election now I'm not
sure exactly New Jersey's laws on a
special election now a lot of a lot of
state laws uh you know they have to it's
so many months until they have the
election unless it's up to the next
election which that would be my guess is
that they're going to have a situation
in New Jersey where they will appoint an
interim Senator if he resigns
and the Democratic governor will appoint
a an interim Senator until 2024 and that
special election in 2024 will likely uh
just fulfill the rest of
uh menendez's term which I'm not exactly
sure
um if he was supposed to be up in 20
um 6 or 28 I'm not really sure at this
moment I haven't found that information
yet um but that that would be my first
guess because that is typical for States
um when they have centered now some
states aren't that way some states uh
are not that way and some State really
honestly you know as much as I want it
to be that way because in this case
we're not going to really we as the
Democrats and having the Senate aren't
going to lose a seat necessarily I mean
it's possible uh in the election but
here's here's the thing is that if you
go back and you look at the rod
begoyovic case Robert gojevich actually
went to prison he was the governor of
Illinois he went to federal prison in
Colorado Trump commuted his sentence
begoyovic went to federal prison for a
long time because he sold
Barack Obama seat when Barack Obama
became the president had to vacate his
senate seat and it became available for
Rod begovic to a point
um when we have a political system that
allows corruption
and sometimes that can breed corruption
but the problem is that when we have uh
politicians the last thing they want to
do
I mean we can't even get the Republicans
to keep the government open folks
we can't even get them to do the simple
function of keeping the government
funded and open let alone at this point
in our timeline
or at this point in our country's
history are we going to get politicians
especially congressmen and senators
in the same room
to undo the corruption that is right at
their fingertips I mean that's going to
be a difficult task if we can't even get
the one of the major political parties
in our country to believe in democracy
one Jesus Christ you'd think that would
be easy and then for them to do the
simple thing is to govern do their
[__] jobs and keep the government
funded and keep our government it's our
government folks it's [__] our it's
not theirs
that's the one [__] problem we have
in this country not just with the
politicians because Bob Menendez
obviously believes that it's his
government
it's his senancy it's his chairmanship
on the Foreign Relations Committee he
owns it it's his it's not the peoples
that's obvious what he believes and the
reason why is because he's selling the
influence of that seat
in the Senate and on the Foreign
Relations Committee he's selling
influence on that seat to him I mean
he's profiting of him it's the same way
Justice Thomas doesn't believe that that
Supreme Court is our Supreme Court it's
[__] ours it ain't Thomas's Court it
ain't Robert's Court
it is our court you [__]
We the People it's ours
and Thomas believes that it's his it's
mine I'm a lifetime appointee it's my
court it's not your court it's not your
Senate it's not your Foreign Relations
Committee
you [__] it's not yours it's
ours we hire you to go do the work of
our government of our Foreign Relations
Committee of our Senate
we we allow you to be a senator to to
confirm United States Supreme Court
Justices and those justices are on our
bench
it is ours
and until we get to that point in our
country where that is our society and
that is it and that is our culture
towards our government and they have
done a great job the fascists in this
country have done a great job at this
destroying
absolutely destroying the notion that
it's our government uh big government
big government deep state right all that
[__]
it's [__] hours that's what makes it
a constitutional republic that's what
makes it a type and form of democracy
you fragile white [__] that are in my
comments saying it's a republic not a
democracy well you need to dust off the
[__] dictionary
at least at a bare minimum you know fire
up Duck Duck Go
okay fire up DuckDuckGo and go with that
hmm okay now let's see let's go to the
clearance Thomas
um I think that's probably
enough for now on Menendez we will be
covering more of Menendez more and more
and more
as Maga capitulates to Trump and they're
gonna go oh look see Democrats correct
Democrats criminals
but they're not going to say that it's
not
is it weaponized
is is Joe Biden's
Democrat
evil blood-sucking cabal doj weaponized
against the Democratic senator the
senior Democratic senator from New
Jersey who is the chairman of the
Foreign Relations can give me a [__]
break if this does not prove
or disprove I should say Jim Jordan and
James quinnon Comer's [__] line that
somehow the government's weaponized
against Donald Trump then it's all then
you are not [__] paying attention
you need to have a cup of coffee sit
down take what brain cells you got left
rub them together a bit
and pluck your head out of your ass okay
so you need to do I mean Jesus Christ we
can't even get the Republicans to get
rid of George Santos who is indicted on
federal charges
and they're going to be oh man they're
going to be totally upset if Menendez
isn't [__] resigned by this afternoon
it is felony Friday
and it smells like a swamp
on okay so I'm going to show you this
the the thumbnail I made for the show
today if you haven't seen it already
here's the thumb there for the show
today
you know that the best part about this
is that three of these [__] are
charged with multiple felonies multiple
felonies and the first one there
Clarence Thomas he should be if he's not
being investigated to be charged with
felonies already
and just I don't know if you're I'm
paying attention but three out of the
four
of these [__] boxes on felony Friday
they're Republican okay they're
Republican
oh man
what a hell of a day what the hell would
they now we're gonna have bone end of
the week coming up here soon
um Gabe Sanchez is working on it he
might be a little late he's feeling a
little under the weather I believe
um but he's still going to join us he's
still going to Brave the show and he's
going to come do bonehead of the week
because we can't not do bonehead of the
week bonehead of the week
um what you're going to want to do here
is you're going to want to subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast you're on
YouTube I need to get better at this
subscribe subscribe subscribe hit that
subscribe button
if you like this show you're going to
want to watch it every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube twitch and
Facebook
now you're not going to want to miss a
single thing from the show and the
reason why is because we show all these
Great Clips now I want to show you the
um the picture
of because a lot of people are talking
about Ken Burns this morning Ken Burns
is trending uh the the documentary
filmmaker
the filmmaker Ken Burns and the reason
why he's trending this morning
is because of this picture right here of
Ken Burns and a Koch brother and I don't
know if you know who this guy is here
that is the um the husband of Q and
honor and famed insurrectionist uh Genie
Thomas he is a Supreme Court Justice
and he's on sale as you see here in the
picture he's on sale for influence uh in
bribery with his with his seat that we
the people have given him on the Supreme
Court uh and apparently he's been going
to all kinds of political functions to
get in front of people that you know
might just have a case that might come
before The Supreme Court and they just
might need a certain way
in a certain you know kind of verdict in
that case
oh boy but Ken Burns is in the middle of
this because he's in that picture
it's kind of wild it's kind of weird and
then why is Ken Burns is he doing is he
doing a film on how corrupt
Clarence Thomas is
is that what he's doing I I have no idea
um but it is kind of funny this morning
that two people on the thumbnail for
felony Friday even though one of them
hasn't been charged with the felonies uh
justice Thomas but but Senator Menendez
has it's kind of funny they both
apparently have a partner in crime you
know partner in life partner in crime
their wife
um because menendez's wife is charged in
this case a bribery and
we all know Genie q and on Thomas
um
loves Insurrection oh she loves a good
coup
I don't know do you have a coup with
white wine or red wine I'm not really
sure
[Laughter]
do you think she do you think she's like
hmm you know what go really good with
this coup some some cheese and some wine
I don't know what do you drink that goes
well with a goo
I don't know
um Clarence Thomas secretly participated
in fundraising Summits for the coke
Network which has brought multiple cases
before The Supreme Court hmm I want to
kind of corruption that could be
wonder wonder what they could have been
doing at the Koch brothers fundraisers
when those Koch brothers wanted to have
cases before The Supreme Court
seems like money Court
Supreme Court Justice it really feels
like to me that's probably not a good
mix feels like
smells like
indictment just saying
um it's possible why is it the why isn't
Clarence Thomas indicted huh why why
what is it do we need a special counsel
in this case do we
I don't know
maybe Tucker Carlson
I'm blurry did I get blurry are people
are saying I'm blurry
am I blurry
are they saying am I blurry did I get
drunk all of a sudden
I don't know maybe it's someone's
connection could be uh let's see here is
um here's a story this morning I was
gonna go with this one to be quite
honest
some people are saying it's clear yes I
have I have bloodshot eye this morning I
have blood it might have been the
drinking I was doing the day before I
don't know
my eyes get bloodshot every once in a
while what am I doing what am I supposed
to do but I was gonna try to run with
this story this morning I don't know if
you guys uh maybe Tucker can do some
reporting on why
you did
apparently he's going to be report
reporting on Russian State TV that's
right you heard it it looks like uh
increasingly like Tucker Carlson is
going to have his own Dub Show on
Russian State TVs rolling News Channel
well God damn
thank you
well God damn the same trailer as two
weeks ago is now being shown on Russia
24 and added caption at the weekend and
this is the screen grab
so literally Tucker is the is on the
network that he really he really
deserves to be on isn't it isn't it
really this is the network that he
deserves to be on really I mean come on
and you know what's funny is like oh
Russia Russia Russia Russia Russia
Russia oh the Russia hoax Russia Russia
Russia really come on man
come on
um
circuit circuit boy scout
says Tony drinks a lot to have kids what
does that mean
what does that mean that I can't I can't
have a drink or two because I have kids
is that what that means
is that what you're saying I mean you
know I'm I'm all for if that's what you
want to have like if you want to have
kids and don't want to drink
and because you got kids but I mean
I don't get crazy or anything
I I don't know
are you saying I can't drink because I
have children and to be honest one of my
one of my kids is damn near old enough
to drink
so like here in a couple years I'll be
able to go to the bar with one of my
children and get wasted with him Legally
Legally wasted so I'm not sure I'm not
sure if you think if I'm younger than
you think I am or something I don't know
I don't know some people get confused
teach its own if you don't want to drink
around your kids don't drink around your
kids no big deal I don't I mean I don't
I don't drink with my kids yet
if that's what you're asking I mean I
mean and
but yeah I don't know hmm
a lot of people tuning in on the um and
tuckums
Tucker Carlson is on Russian TV isn't
that crazy
isn't that crazy
circuit boy scout said yes that's what I
meant no offense I I'm not offended did
it did it appear I was offended I'm not
offended teach his own if you don't want
to drink in front of your kids don't do
it don't do it if that's what you don't
want to do no problem and if you get
like if you get violent
and you probably shouldn't be drinking I
was talking about this with someone this
morning speaking of felonies right
Hunter Biden has been charged with
Firearms charges which I actually think
people who have a history of abuse and
drug and alcohol should not have
firearms I don't think they should have
firearms and really honestly
if you are a person
who likes to partake in those things it
is probably a good idea that you do not
have easy access to firearms
just shows
in data that that is not a good
combination drugs alcohol and Firearms
not a good combo now do I think that we
should be charging every Tom Dick and
Harry with these felonies
or should we be doing what we should be
doing with most problems in this country
when it comes to I don't know health
especially when it comes to mental
health and someone's trying to
self-medicate through alcohol and drugs
which it appears what Hunter Biden
possibly could have been doing I
actually believe we should seek help for
them
right we should give them our support as
the people as the government there are
countrymen for crying out loud I don't
care if it's Hunter Biden or it's you
know Wanda down the street uh who has a
problem with alcohol and she's got
firearms in her house I don't give a
[__] who it is
the problem is is that their
interpretation
of the Second Amendment right it's it's
their interpretation of the second
amendment that puts them in a fuzzy spot
about this
so when you're talking about
the what about ISM of who's charged and
who's not and two-tiered Justice I mean
I know it sounds like I'm drawing in
rather you can drink in front of your
kids or not but really honestly these
are questions for our individual liberty
and some of them are not questions for
our individual liberty but we should
have the Liberty to [__] seek
treatment for mental illness whatever
whether it be a traumatic event PTSD
whatever whatever it may be that you're
that if you're abusing drugs and alcohol
to self-medicate maybe we should have
access
Healthcare in that form and fashion
now I I don't know I don't believe that
my drug and alcohol use is abusive
it may be abusive to myself that's for
sure I mean I'm sure it's killing brain
cells you know
hopefully just saying ignorance is bliss
can't you tell can't you tell
but no to some extent any drug or
alcohol use could be considered abuse or
self-medication or whatever but I know I
personally and you guys know that I'm
I'm very transparent I don't try to beat
around the bush of who I am and what I
do I personally use it for recreation
more than anything and I don't over I
used to overdo it a lot I don't overdo
it that much anymore
um but occasional drink now and then is
not a bad thing I don't think
for someone to use recreationally as
long as they don't get out of hand but
if you are an abuser you probably
shouldn't have a firearm
probably shouldn't that's probably
something we as a society should
consider that someone who is struggling
with mental problems especially if
they're using drug and alcohol to
self-medicate those whatever health
problems that they're having
we should probably consider that they
shouldn't possess Firearms they should
not that they shouldn't own them they
just shouldn't possess them there's a
difference
there's a [__] world of difference
and maybe maybe just maybe someone who
has a problem now and can't possess
Firearms may not have that problem in
the future they may fix that problem
Hunter Biden seems to be
um very very very
uh working hard
on fixing the problems that he had now
rather he'll be able to fix them
entirely and and and rid himself
of the issues that he has where he has
to be abused drug and alcohol
um you know I I that question Still
Remains which means that the possession
of his firearm should probably remain
away from him right
who who wants anyone to hurt themselves
or other people
with a firearm you know what I mean so
you know when we're considering this
what about this and I know I took a
roundabout you know a detour here but I
appreciate the sentiment and I
appreciate that you know you say no
offense
um I'm not offended that's the
difference and that's how we should be
in this country
that's how we should be in this country
someone can have their own opinion about
whether you should have a drink in front
of your children or not whatever age you
might think they are
but you can't you you know again we have
to have some freedom and some Liberty
that's the whole point of liberalism so
um
you also say and I keep talking to the
same person on Twitter circuit boys got
to say feel for Hunter I'm uh in
recovery for opioid addiction yeah I
mean again again the same thing you
probably shouldn't when when you're in
recovery or you're abusing drugs or
alcohol you probably shouldn't have
access to Firearms not not just
not just because of other people because
your own safety so
okay I'm speaking of safety what we need
to do
is definitely not have Tucker on our
mainstream medium right
when he's going when he's gonna have a
show on Russia TV yeah probably not a
thing that we should do
all right thanks Tucker for taking a
back seat I really wanted that to be the
lead up I'm not gonna lie really wanted
it to be the lead up
whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a second here
here is this the
is this the ad here's the ad here's the
ad on registered let's listen
Russia Russia Russia Russia Russia
Russian Russia
Russia Russia Russia 24.
what the actual [__]
oh my God
oh my God are you kidding me
oh man
Dr Carlson Russia Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia Russia Russia
hahaha
ah Tucker you treasonous piece of [__]
what a piece of trash he is
what a [__] treasonous piece of trash
oh man and Tucker Carlson Tucker [__]
Carlson talking about a treasonous piece
of [__]
um and talking about Russia yesterday
Kevin McCarthy would not give time to
president zielinski the president of
Ukraine to speak on the house floor he
just doesn't have time because he's he's
too busy putting his Cheeto dust knee
pads on for that let's let's listen to
McChicken here as someone calls him in
the chat McChicken did you turn down the
joint uh session of Congress first uh so
let's get asked for a joint session we
just didn't have time he's already given
a joint session so what we're doing for
um
for zielinski is exactly the same thing
that we did for the prime minister of
the UK the prime minister of Italy were
putting the bipartisan uh group of
members together to meet with no
different than we did with anybody else
and this is a little busy week we're
dealing with the funding issue I don't
know how we could slip that into such a
short time so what do you hey I tell you
what you could slip in your little [__]
I know any way you could slip in how
about you should have done your [__]
job months ago huh how about that Kev
you [__] you disgusting piece of
trash maybe you should have done your
[__] job months ago instead of
[__] talking about Hunter Biden's
dick
how about that how about you should have
you should have gotten your [__]
caucus together and said hey we're gonna
stop the [__] lies about Joe Biden
and Hunter Biden and stop this nonsense
and do our jobs
do our [__] jobs that way in
September we're not a week away from
shutting down the government that we
can't keep this [__] open
our one bare minimum [__] job that we
have to do is to keep the government
open
maybe that's what you should have done
Kev huh maybe you should have treated
maybe you should have treated our
government with the respect that it
[__] deserves but you don't because
you don't give a [__] because you only
care about your own [__] power and
who gives it to you and that's Donald
Jessica Trump
that's it
this [__] scumbag the only thing he
gives a [__] about is his power and the
only person who gives it to him one one
person gives Kevin McCarthy the ability
to run around the capitol acting like
he's the speaker of the cat house
because he's not he's pretending to be
the Speaker of the House the speaker of
the house actually is the leader of the
House of Representatives and the leader
of their caucus and it is clear and
Kevin McCarthy is none of those
none of those things
he's only pretending
to be the speaker in the house Donald
Trump is a speaker in the house if you
want to know
the truth
no boy Kevin
all right let's go um you know what you
know what though I want to show you
something oh man you're gonna love this
oh you're gonna love this [__] out of
this
you know I've shown you clips of the
Pete Buddha judge Department of
Transportation uh Committee in the house
and um Scott Perry just didn't
understand how subsidies work didn't
understand how EV worked and how
capitalism worked how markets work how
the automobile industry works really
Scott Perry doesn't understand anything
but how to overthrow trying to help
Trump overthrow the government
if I may
but I'm going to show you even a [__]
[__]
a dead a brain dead [__]
can seem to be a functional member of
Congress
it is a possibility
what is hilarious
is that is that representative bird [__]
here
brain dead [__]
even admits out loud that the only
reason why
that he is going to seemingly be a
functional member of Congress for a
couple minutes while he has the floor to
ask the Department of Transportation
secretary Pete bootages questions
he admits that all the questions that
would get him sound bites are now gone
but watch this this is this is [__]
incredible this is actually the boring
stuff the government is supposed to do
and I know government isn't sexy it's
not it's hard to make it sexy that's why
they talk about Hunter Biden's [__] and
lamp tops and bribes that don't exist
oh by the way hmm I wonder if um there's
any DNA on gold bars or or cashed Up In
Pockets at Biden's residence I don't
know probably not uh you know it's just
a Witch Hunt uh anyways here is here is
a a [__]
seeming to be a functional member of
Congress asking boring unsexy questions
that need to be asked to the Secretary
of the Department of Transportation it's
wild stuff but watch I was a county
mayor and that's the best outcome job I
ever had I know we both come from that
background that's about where the
similarities end but um and since I am
the uh 435th most powerful member of
Congress and I'm one of the last people
to ask the questions all the good ones
have been asked all the gotchas that are
going to get me a good YouTube plug are
gone so I'm just going to ask you some
serious stuff if that's okay with you
brother oh my God
did you hear what he just said
now I I know he's half joking here but
he's he's actually serious to some
degree
he's one of the last one to ask
questions and all the questions that
were already the gotchas
the the [__] that's going to be on
played on Trader TV News Network
everywhere about all that that gay guy
he wants to give you gay electric
vehicles or some dumb [__] whatever
they're gonna sell over there
whatever the hell they're gonna sell
over there on Trader TV's News Network
I'm sure that's the I'm sure that's the
narrative that they're going with is
Mayor Pete's trying to make you gay by
making you buy gay EVS or some dumb [__]
who knows
I mean they always they always have to
do this with mayor Pete as if as if
electric vehicles and the government's
job to make sure
that when the Market opens for electric
vehicles that this country and the
people are ready in this country and the
government's ready in this country
somehow has to do with who Pete Buda
judge goes to bed with at night I mean
that's all they can focus on is someone
else's genitalian someone else's
sexuality
but I digress from that because it is
refreshing that's that representative
bird [__] here as much of as much as of
a of a brain dead idiot he is he's gonna
ask a serious question okay well let's
hear about the serious question here it
actually is a serious question it's
remarkable let's watch sounds good
um why have
State Departments of Transportation been
slow to use reclaimed asphalt pavement
oh boy now again this is not going to
get him any attention
on Trader TV news networks
this is the most unsexy thing
anyone could talk about in Congress
about highways
his question was why in the hell isn't
State Departments of Transportation
doing more to use and recycle asphalt
and the reason why is because
well let me show you well let's listen
here because Pete kind of answers it
it's it's it's a beautiful moment in um
I don't know governance just seems it's
crazy to put that stuff in the landfill
I think it's a great question
um and uh maybe another area it turns
out we have something in common is a a
belief that we ought to be paying more
attention to materials the sourcing of
pavement uh the durability of pavement
one thing I would
mention is that I think often local
jurisdictions are under such pressure in
the short term just get the potholes
filled you and I think both both
experienced it with the roads we were in
charge of that even if you were offered
something that represented a savings for
the long run unless it lets you get
another uh X number of Lane miles done
this year you might feel compelled to
say no
oh boy isn't that your sexy government
talk oh man talking about potholes and
filling potholes and saving x amount of
dollars on material for payment
again it's not sexy
but this is the [__] that governments do
okay now
Pete put a judge I just want I just want
to give you a lesson
in what the [__] is going on here
of why this this
[__] bird [__] represented who should
not be a member of Congress by the way I
do not think he's qualified to be a
member of Congress I do not believe that
just because he asked one good question
does not make him qualified to be a
member of Congress
but let me tell you what's going on here
people to judge is the the Secretary of
Transportation for the federal
government okay now the federal
government can't really tell a state
what material they're going to use for
their highways right
they can't really I mean they can a
little bit and the reason why is because
a lot of Highway funding is federal
funding right it's what a lot of the
infrastructure money the Democrats
passed not Republicans Democrats past
a lot of it's Highway money you know to
fix Road your roads your Bridges rather
you're in a blue state or red State now
the red State people who voted against
it are going to try to take credit for
it they're lying to you if you're out
there listening to me in a red state
they're going to lie to you they're
going to take credit for all kinds of
funding that the federal government
passed for your highways
but in generally speaking the federal
government doesn't get to tell the
states what material they're going to
use on what highways
generally speaking now what the federal
government can do
is do its job to make sure that it
provides the information that the states
need to understand why they should be
using X Y and Z materials for their
highways got it do you understand that
that is the [__] role of government a
lot of times is collecting enough
information to know what we should be
doing
not just not just because it's the right
thing to do
because it saves what's that [__]
thing they're always wanting Republicans
and corporations and rich people what is
that thing that's it's it's almost like
Bob Melinda's had it stuffed in a
[__] envelope in his jacket pocket
with DNA of his criminal conspirators
all over it money money
folks money
so listen to Mayor Pete here now again
I'm sure that representative bird [__]
here wants decent highways in his
district
and really honestly it's one thing that
politicians do that is like a thing that
they go and they sell to their
constituents for reelection imagine
imagine if in the district you lived in
every [__] highway and every [__]
Bridge was just [__] just absolute
[__] garbage you had to buy new
goddamn tires every year because the
[__] the [__] State and Highway
Department won't fix the [__] roads
and bridges they're just garbage you
might as well drive on grab a roads 24
7. then drive on the paved roads that
the state's taking care of because
they're just potholes and just [__]
right imagine a politician says you
elect me and I'll make sure to get you
[__] tax dollars to pay to fix these
[__] roads that you hate and then lo
and behold two years later [__] roads
and bridges are being fixed baby
pavement brand new pavement
brand new Bridges it might be a [__]
because you know you got to detour
traffic around while they're doing it
get through road construction but when
it's all said and done
represent representative pavement comes
back to the district and says hey
remember when I told you I was going to
get rose page and 50s [__] shitty
roads like the last guy wouldn't well I
did
I got them fixed Who you gonna [__]
vote for huh
Who you gonna vote for you're gonna vote
for the guy who's trying to sell you
line items and bills that don't exist
are you going to vote for the guy or gal
that got your [__] shitty ass roads
fixed
you know what makes a damn good
politician a really damn good politician
a really damn good politician
someone who not only fights for
democracy but fights for their [__]
District to get funded
do you know that that is one [__]
that is one attribute of a damn good
politician
especially when it's for physical
infrastructure like roads and bridges
schools
a good example here in Missouri is they
have no fault clause on schools here in
Missouri years ago decades and decades
ago
there was a ton of crony politicians
that redid the education funding system
right
and the crony politicians made sure the
districts they lived in were whole
harmless the state couldn't [__] with
their funding they could [__] with other
districts funding because those
politicians didn't have as much power
but they made sure they sold that
that's what makes a good [__]
politician is someone who not only
believes in our democracy
and believes in our form of government
but believes in bringing the funding
that their constituents deserve
Republicans do not do that kind of stuff
but let's listen to Pete here talk about
research and trying to get States
to listen to the research that the
government pays for so they can save
Bob and Linda's gold bars
we'd like to change those incentives uh
Federal highways take seriously that
it's not our job to dictate to local
governments uh things as detailed as
what kind of uh construction materials
they ought to use but we're trying to
get and we've published information
trying to get more out there about
reclaimed and recycled Pavements and
more generally we do have some research
that we fund at many institutions around
the country on improving pavement
durability generally because I think
there's if you can make the payment
asphalt we do have last just one or two
percent longer in effect you're saving
billions of dollars right there I think
it deserves more attention and it's
ridiculous to throw this stuff in the
landfill it's just wasted if you would
just commit to me to have somebody call
me this isn't a gotcha this is an honest
situation I think we could get a
bipartisan group to work on that could
you do that for me brother I'd be happy
to I'd love to explore that with you and
tell me how to say your last name one
more time you can just call me pizza go
to judge okay I'm a merchant and nobody
ever gets that right either so that's
right I never get it right either Gabe
Sanchez I call him bird [__] because
that's what it sounds like to me now
what what's crazy here is in this clip
is that welcome to the show by the way
how you feeling uh are you feeling are
you feeling like bird [__] I'm feeling
like bird [__] yeah oh okay okay I know
you were feeling under the weather yeah
well welcome to the show again but
here's the thing is that as unsexy as
this clip is this is a prime example of
how even a [__]
like Senator bird [__] here
can seemingly be a functional member of
Congress if they I don't know just ask
questions that their constituents would
want to [__] know like literally
literally there's not a constituent out
there
that what doesn't want to know what is
my Congress person doing about the
shitty highways that are out in the
world there that I drive on I mean about
that I caught the the tail end of that
clip and I didn't see because it was all
it was all in Pete first
uh I didn't know who was speaking and to
my mind I was like oh is this why is
this person like being cordial right it
just seems so out for a guy who goes it
is what it is kids are dying from gun
violence I can't really do anything but
I will make sure that my own children
are homeschooled because I know the
dangers of those guns in schools this
guy's like oh I'm sorry excuse me how do
you say your name and I don't know if
that was an attempt to make fun but it
came out sincere and Pete was like yeah
just call me Pete whatever all right
well my name's and he's like well my
name's bird [__] and everyone thinks my
name is bird [__] and they they get it
totally wrong you think he's listening
when I go when we call him bird [__]
yeah that's I mean when he when he was
like oh Tim birchett and I was like it
sounds like bird [__] I mean he said
he's as as useless as bird [__] we know
that right after he made those well
insane comments you know what's funny
about the the comments that he made
about guns he's like no there's just
nothing we can do about guns not a
goddamn thing but but we can make sure
that pavement doesn't end up in
landfills like dude if we can do the one
thing we can certainly do the other like
it's not there's not a choice it's not a
choice between can we have children can
we prevent children from being murdered
in school by weapons of war or or you're
going to get paid man out of landfills
you can have one or the other you don't
get to get you know also one might seem
easier than the other you know and one
also might seem like it has uh I don't
know uh short like massive short-term
benefits if we save children now
then we can save ourselves money
heartache uh other sorts of pain if we
have Asphalt in landfills like yeah
that'd be great long term but it's like
I mean also saving children is a
long-term benefit as well but are you
are you set are you saying that that
lives all lies I'm not saying that all
asphalt round material matters
all children's lives matter they do they
do they do matter oh my God how do we
get there all right so um we're gonna do
bonehead of the week and we got to do
rapid fire don't we and we've got like
30 minutes we're going to make it I'm
like I'm like burning on I'm running on
fumes right now are you really because
you you sent and you're like I just woke
up so yeah I dude I've been [__] deal
with this sickness man so so you were
supposed what happened this week what
happened while I'm loading in assets
because that's what I was supposed to go
see family yes
um you got sick and I got sick and I was
unable I was just like dead was not not
one traveling sick is terrible
and two I was not about to go
you know cough on [__] and you know that
I I didn't want I didn't want to I
didn't run it wasn't it was I'll say
this less about the people I was
traveling with because I don't know
anyone but I also wanted to be courteous
and respectful of that but also my
family
I didn't want to go around and be like
oh hey you know coughing them and give
them something is it covered uh no I've
tested multiple times it's not coveted
it's just the flu
um so I'm just like run down said dirty
sanchez type stuff I don't know how I
got it where I got it from but luckily
it was not it's not covered ah well
that's good that's good and and let's so
let's get into it let's get to the bone
of the week everyone stick around we'll
be right back with bonehead of the week
right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day I'm recurring
and it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] them
we're
to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show it's
Friday September 22nd and it's felony
Friday Bell news for you found it for
you you get a felony you get a felony
you get a felony oh there's a few
Democrats over here you get a felony too
why not
it's not weaponized against it man
oh boy I saw I haven't even looked into
this did something happen with George
Santos well no but I mean but it is I
mean you guys charged without he is he
is charged with felonies Trump's charged
with felonies Thomas should be charged
with felonies if Democratic senator Bob
Menendez is charged with felonies which
he is today
um I just figured felony Friday we were
in the uh we're in the pre-show and I
was talking I was like Jesus Christ
there's so many [__] criminals and uh
I think it was mighty librarian said
yeah it's felony Friday there you go
yeah I saw George Santos on the
thumbnail and I thought oh did something
happen and then I Googled and I was like
did something happen no nothing happened
oh okay so you you put him on the
thumbnail I got excited thinking oh
maybe I'll throw them into bonehead
this is this is how it's misleading man
oh my God man I really I really [__]
you up this morning didn't I you got
excited when you saw that down there I
woke up I woke up yeah oh God like I
feel like [__] and I was like George
Santos oh man what'd he do you're like
Bing Bing Bing I feel like a million
bucks I was like I just got a shot of
adrenaline
and then I Googled and the most
recent thing was maybe a few days ago
where he did not submit his financials
and because what he'll probably he'll
probably catch another felony for that
George Santos just a couple days ago
uh
uh George he missed his extended
deadline to file Financial disclosure
blames fear of a rushed job well that is
true anyway when you when you got when
you got to get rushed you gotta lie
that's that's George Santos in a
nutshell well we got we got boneheads of
the week for you here um let's do the
Muse they always like to do the music
first dude let's do the flute
[Music]
[Applause]
um
bonehead of the week and boy do we have
some bonehead Senator Tommy two branches
tuberville we have Matt I love to think
about your children's genitalia Walsh
and
Kevin McChicken I mean McCarthy uh
speaker representative maybe not for
very long he won't be and for very long
so he might I mean he might still be
Center or he might still be a
representative
I'm gonna say I'm gonna say if if they
vote to vacate his chair he will resign
Bakersfield is a you know no offense to
Bakersfield but it typically is a is a
drive-through area uh it's a farming
land drive by or drive through which one
did you say it's a drive through and I
say drive through because I drive
through it but also because I stop at
like in and out on a road trip when I'm
going up and so how is the in and out
there at Bakersfield it's not bad okay
so hey props to props to Kevin McCarthy
for allowing that Land Development to be
a lot you know for an oasis kind of
situation right there the the but yeah
uh there's not much and look I know
there may be someone from uh Bakersfield
listening if you are awesome glad to
have you but if you're not you know no
offense to the people who aren't
listening
but I just never it's not I don't know
it's not that great I know they have a
high crime rate I know that yeah it's
like one of the highest in the country
yeah per capita well let's let's go to
tuberville First speaking of
um boneheads
tuberville you know he's had a blockade
on
um
promotions in the military because he he
likes the word abortion he doesn't
really know what it means he didn't know
why but he likes the word abortion he
says a lot he says abortion abortion
abortion bread of abortion what I I said
abortion why did you say that well
because of abortion that's why I said
abortionate nobody ever said abortion
right why are you why are you just
throwing that out of here but here's the
thing is that uh Tommy two Branch
tubbervilles blockade on uh the dod
promotion has kind of come to a stop and
the reason why is because Democrats are
now going to do them one by one
um where they wanted to vote on all
these things all at once for these
promotions and the ability for these
promotions now they're just gonna have
to just do them like single yeah one by
one by one so the blockade is coming
down uh here is a uh clip
of Tommy oh what the hell
there we go here's here's a clip of uh
Tommy two branches here on Fox Business
uh about this issue I believe let's
listen better I want to talk to you
about about a bunch of things but but
permit me I want to just jump in you
kind of I'm saying tubberville 10
Schumer zero uh you forced him into
voting specifically on some of these top
Military Officers uh Joint Chiefs
Marines Army uh take a Victory lap
Center towerville Schumer did what he
said he wouldn't do
so I love how these both of these bow
ninja like yeah it's a victory for you
like yeah but it's a loss for the
country because they could just trust
the dod like they always do yeah like
they always do they can trust the dod
with their [__] recommendations of
promotion and say yes let's just get
these promotions over with but no they
want to waste America's time so
congratulations to Tommy tuberville for
wasting the senate in America's time on
doing these promotions one by one by one
what a [__] jack off
am I missing something here is he is
this a lamp that he's running this is
you know this is very uh
on par for the Republican party they
don't care I mean look at the government
shutdown right we're going to cover that
in a little bit but like
look at the government shutdown you have
Republicans or House Republicans are
like well we did all we could do guys
let's go home
and they leave and who is going to be
you know who who's going to be covering
the bill us we're going to be on the
receiving end of that decision because
Republicans don't have the votes they
ever need they're a party that is just
about owning the libs and every time
it's a rake step for themselves and they
just continue to do it again and again
and again and we as the American people
as the constituents of these elected
officials find ourselves in the
difficult position because we literally
can't do anything
until you know an election comes around
because until then
we're left holding the bag you know
the crazy part about this the the
Victory lap that kiddo's talking about
him to take here
um is that they blocked the Air Force
General Charles Q brown from being the
chairman of Joint Chiefs of Staff which
if you go back and you look who
appointed
Charles Q brown to be the Air Force
General before they just voted for him
to be promoted to chairman of Joint
Chiefs do you know what president was
huh do you know what president was who
made
um Charles Q brown the Air Force General
I don't know there's a last name start
with T yes it's Trump so so Tommy Tommy
two reveal prevented all that [__]
all the all the nonsense for a trump
appointed Air Force General to become
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs because
that's really the story here is that the
the [__] military and the dod isn't
each president's different DOD yeah a
president doesn't come in office like
okay everyone's fired new military
that's not how it works well I mean
that's what they want to do with project
2025 essentially but but that's but
that's what I'm saying is that's not
actually how it happens is DoD is not
part of what we elect as the president
United States or what we elect as the
Senate we elect the Senators to make
sure to have oversight over them and to
make sure that that oversight is done
properly and Tommy too real was not
doing it properly that's why that
bonehead ended up on bonehead of the
week now let's move to the next bonehead
Matt I have Super hypers Hyper focus on
your children's genitalia Walsh
really weird stuff I'm not gonna lie
he's really weird when he does this
stuff but there's a new thing that Matt
Walsh did and he talked about here
recently that has nothing to do with
your children's genitalia which is
amazing to me that he's actually focused
on something other than that so I want
to tell Matt this may be movement in
your illness that you may have where
you're just absolutely focused the
problem is is that Matt Walsh is a
fascist through and through
so yeah what he wants to do is he wants
to make sure that people he don't like
can't vote
yeah oh my God so I've been saying if
you see his new his new [__] logo
that why does it look you know what you
know what it looks like yeah what is it
well kind of not really I the first
thing I had in my mind was it reminded
me of the West Virginia University logo
yeah a little bit but there's another
logo that reminds me of and I gotta
think of it but when I saw it I was like
uh oh God MW [__] dumb I gotta tell
you Matt I don't appreciate you copying
me by having a TV behind you with your
logo on it that kind of pisses me off
I'm actually thinking about getting my
lawyers to send you a cease and desist
this is kind of ridiculous but I'm I'm
not going to get go that far into the
commentary on man what I want to do is
play for you this little clip that he
had on his show and then I'm gonna say I
told you so probably I don't know 15 20
times here so let's listen
these people should not be allowed to
vote I mean you hear people say that in
a half joking way oh I can't believe
these people can vote
but but really they shouldn't be able to
like actually they should not be able to
vote
that should be something that we
that becomes a serious topic of
conversation
now he almost he almost said what he
really wanted to say didn't he that we
white guys white dudes white property
owning dudes like it says you know in
the Constitution that we should make
sure that they them others well he's
gonna say no I mean you know he's just
shy of saying the founding fathers did
it right right woman no person of color
you're white you're a man and that's
pretty much it you need to be rich you
need to learn he'll probably say you
know what we need to do is we're going
to DNA test everyone to make sure that
you're as close to 100 of that Supreme
race right right well you know last I
don't know it was this week I believe I
think it was this week I was talking
about how they don't want women to vote
they don't and they don't want women in
the military and someone's like
someone's place they want him is in the
home you know well that's right
barefooting in the kitchen but they they
someone sent a comment they're like
where where where are they doing this
Tony you're such a [__] liar you're
such a [__] liar oh I know what it
was it was in it was in Discord it was
this [__] guy Kurt who thinks who
thinks he's a Libertarian that's where
it was at he was like oh Tony's saying
this stuff they don't actually want that
hey [__] hey Kurt open your [__]
ears man open your ears and listen to
this fascist here listen
okay like the kind of thing that comes
up on presidential debates
okay look an issue that political
parties have to deal with in their
platforms
should really be talking about this
but there are a lot of people who are
voting in this country who should not
have that right
they don't deserve it
and as I've tried to explain many times
the right to vote it is not a god-given
right guaranteed to everybody regardless
of anything
it's not oh okay it's not it's not
fundamental to your human nature it
automatically are entitled to have a say
over the
you know political system in your
country
tell us more about the fascism
guidelines that should be in place you
should you should have to earn that
right tell us more about your fascism
tell us about your fashion it's so
incredibly obvious
oh it's obvious that you're a fashion
you are an absolute oblivious [__]
which you are nothing
about your own country
or the political or the or the
government
uh that runs it
then you shouldn't have any say over it
I mean if that's the case then Donald
Trump wouldn't even come close to being
president if we did what he's saying
because honestly the majority of the
people who vote for Trump have no
[__] clue
no [__] clue I just I just love it's
like okay look every one of these
two-way bro 1A bro you know all that
[__]
it's almost like oh God I'm sorry to say
it but it's like you have a you have a
keyboard in front of you you have a
phone in your pocket that you're always
on you know on PornHub we know you're on
there guys
I would I would you know what I would go
out in bed someone else can do the
research on this one I would bet that
you could probably go to Pornhub and you
could type in inalienable rights yeah or
voting rights and I guarantee there is
some premise of a porn that is
surrounded around that that explains
what the [__] those things are there's
porn for everything is that what you're
saying I'm saying that they could easily
they could go to their favorite fetish
and I'm sure one of those fetishes have
something easy easy because some of that
stuff's illegal I mean Matt here Matt
here has a lot of fetishes and a lot of
those weird stuff underaged uh
it's very easy guys all you got to do is
you type in inaliable rights or you type
in the right to vote and you get the
answer right there that's it you're
God's even right the right that you're
given when you are born you are a
citizen is that you have the ability to
to vote that you have the ability to
voice your opinion on a candidate or a
policy or something that is being done
within your area or you know regionally
nationally whatever it is but you have
the ability
to
Mark what you want on the ballot because
you have the right to vote
well I thought this was a good
bone-headed moment oh for man Walsh from
Matt Walsh because I didn't know about
this until you mentioned that he was a
candidate last night I looked up I was
like holy [__] I'm [__] kidding me
finally finally they're saying the part
that I've been saying they're gonna say
out loud for a while right because this
is this is more of the Vivek [__]
because uh vivex trying to do a campaign
to appeal to young people even though
he's like I don't want young people to
vote and then they changed it a little
bit they're like no young people who
take a test right you gotta there's
gotta be a test for it which we've went
through this in history that there
there's no test there's no there's no
test you don't have to you don't have to
do a test if you want to be a citizen of
this country then that's a test and
they're comparing it to that from
someone who wants to become Asis have
you have you heard the update on Vivek
ramaswamy no but I'm sure it's
boneheaded so it probably so you know
how he's like oh the citizenship you
take a test is people who want to come
into this country you know this what
about his family were they yeah well
here's the thing Tony it turns out it
turns out are they not citizens his
father is not a citizen oh wow even
though he's referred to as parents to
you know sell the idea of this American
Dream taking the citizen Citizenship
style so you mean he's lying
you know what you're saying oh well the
fake the fake ramaswamy and some people
say Vivek the snake but Vivek the snake
makes him sound cool right it makes him
sound like he's you know a wrestler
right it makes him sound like he's
actually of Merit Vivek the fake is the
only way that I will ever call referred
to it okay the fake
the fake uh and that's where Matt Walsh
is doing this
Vivek The Rake too Vivek Vivek who steps
on the rake yeah who is a fake fake who
steps on a rake that's right who's
definitely not a snake no
but he didn't eat a snake oil salesman
and he could he could maybe that's where
the snake comes in yeah yeah speaking
speaking of snake oil salesman uh you
have
um Rudy kaluti Grandpa farty mccharty
Rooney Giuliani on the dishonorable
mention I have no clue why he's on this
honorable you don't know no what kind of
what happened like groped his way to the
Finish Line there oh okay I I didn't
know which one it was because apparently
apparently uh sheamos and Ruby Freeman
uh the judges said no [__] you're going
You're gonna pay these women for the
[__] [__] you did to them yeah um
because there was that too in the last
week but you're talking about the fact
on January 6th cooing made made original
Giuliani so [__] horny I mean I mean
you know when you get a good coup going
yeah I'm not gonna lie you get a good
kugo and it might you know work you up
into boner City you know what I'm saying
you know and then what he did it did the
same thing he did on Borat too well he
didn't touch him so
yeah he might have been tucking while he
was trying to grope Cassidy Hutchison
but apparently on January 6th which was
crazy when I heard Rudy Giuliani groped
Cassidy Hudson I'm like oh okay well
that makes sense and then someone's like
no it was on January 6th that day I'm
like whoa what yeah that guy was really
he was like oh oh man I'm [__] edging
uh he's like oh I'm so excited oh we're
gonna [__] storm the capital I need
to get some boobies you know he's like
and he just goes because we know if you
look at the if you look at the
uh
uh the comments that he made towards his
former
um
employee yeah who's selling it who is
suing him for 10 million dollars million
dollars now is this the same one that
has the tapes of him like oh those are
my boobies give me those boobies the
booby boobies I love the boobies
that would be uh Rudy the booby man
Julian listen I and I've said this the
last few weeks with the other bonehead
bobert who was juicing the beetle in the
theater I'm not opposed to consensual
Hooter honking there's nothing wrong
with consensual Hooter honking whatever
you want to do if you want to
consensually Hooter honk go for it but
apparently this was not consensual and
we've got um Justin we've got a um we've
got an image of Rudy uh
um he's about to do a press conference I
think on um why
why he should definitely not be a
um a lawyer anymore it just doesn't when
I every time I see that photo or I watch
that video of him just going you can
hire me on Cami or whatever the [__] he
says
uh
I just can't I cannot accept the fact
that this is a real thing
I cannot accept the fact that one there
are shorts that are quite possibly look
like pants of a small child they are
they look like they're drinking jeans
right do you guys remember jinko jeans
oh yeah I'm pretty sure jeans I think
jinko jeans are making a comeback by the
way are they really yeah this is one of
those moments where I'm like no do not
repeat the fashion history I owned a
listen I owned a couple pairs of jinko
jeans and they were [__] bad oh yeah
they were super great
mops on the ground
I had a pair that had a white and red
racing stripe down each side they were
Bennett and then I had the Doc Martin
were you like super fast down the
hallway I was I was in in you know in
between the lockers and [__] yeah and I
think it was uh eighth grade that's when
jinko jeans yeah yeah
sounds like they're coming back I mean I
feel like this is the conversation I
have with my parents when they're like
oh bell bottoms those seem to be coming
back we did those and when we were kids
and I was shut up mom no you didn't all
right yeah all right whatever Mom
whatever did this is that exact same
moment now I I'm seeing stuff like the
Kangol fuzzy uh bucket hat and the
spaghetti straps coming back and the
Janko jeans and I'm like are we gonna do
the whole overall where are you where
you clip them together and you fold them
down
remember that are you talking about the
the overalls yeah that's what I'm saying
I've seen I've seen some people wear
overalls where it's down at their waist
folded down yeah that's what I'm saying
that was a thing that was a thing I've
seen some people wear those where I'm
like guys this
it's like maybe this bonehead starts
wearing overalls I don't know I don't
know I mean it reminds me of like the
blocky shoes the like Balenciaga and
other ones I'm like those are goddamn
Skechers man I remember wearing those as
a kid and they're so blocky and then
other kids like oh those bloody shoes
if we were to only fast forward like 20
years I would be in a position where I'd
be like oh yeah look at me I'm so
fashionable
now Rudy Giuliani not not a fashionable
guy an absolute creep never will be on
uh you know in Vogue right or on the
runway but this guy's style choice right
now his pants again they look like you
know what they look like they look like
parachute pants for a small child
and he's got him up above what what
looks like especially his belly button
maybe I have no idea what's going on I
just want to know like
it is this what this like is it is that
what he's tucking in like is he tucking
in his stomach and his shirt and
everything
I don't know but you know what I will
tell you the next bonehead we have they
love bomber fashion pipe bomber oh
apparently they like that look they like
the bike pipe bomber look I'm just
saying I'm just saying now the alpha
guck is Marjorie Taylor green now
again I have to ask because I'm not
really sure why I mean there could be I
send you the link okay so this is this
is the reason why she's
the the alpha cook yeah I mean there's
probably a thousand different reasons
why but this one in particular she made
a video this morning okay
now I I have to point out number one one
reason why she's out cook is because she
literally is using
the mug shot background on her this is
this is her [__] oh don't worry that
mug shot there's an interview she gave
where she talks about you know this uh
the government shutdown oh no she's
sorry she talks about the impeachment
and in the interview no no impeachment I
asked no no meachman is Lauren bobert oh
this is impeach treatment and Peachtree
dish yeah and Peach Tree dish okay okay
yeah yeah okay so what you have here is
she uses this photo for a profile which
is God damn the [__] funniest own
I've ever heard or seen but she also did
an interview with a local Georgia radio
show that sounded like they were very
much in support of her and Donald Trump
and on the on they're like oh here's the
clip segment they use her photo
of of the Photoshop Fulton County
mugshot as as what are they supposed to
do
I don't know man they could have used
her with one of those guys she had an
affair with so what that what the hell
is this about is she this video it says
here's why I'm not in Washington right
now she made a 12 and a half minute clip
okay I've heard it of her in her gym in
her garage
where she goes off explaining she
doesn't work out in the video okay she's
just in front and she says
uh just her pre-workout routine or
afterwards I have no idea I I don't know
I don't know it's a good question
but in the video in the original caption
she says here's why I'm not in
Washington right now because you're a
[__] idiot
that's why because you're a useless
piece of [__] and you have nothing
better to do and you're all about
performative politics and you don't have
any change in mind and the only reason
you're not there is because you couldn't
have the votes and now you're allowing
the government to shut down and you're
doing whatever Kevin McCarthy wants and
whatever Trump wants yeah sorry yeah
Trump and even people in your own caucus
[__] hate your guts like Matt Gates
who even called out Kevin McCarthy was
like this guy's an idiot I'm gonna kick
them all these down again
but in the video she quotes it and says
uh if you pulled the Tweet
um
there we go she goes I'm so mad I did a
live video this morning in my garage
with no makeup on
okay now I'm organizing an emergency
Town Hall in my District's night that's
not gonna do [__] America first American
flag
this dumbass
I thought that this was like some sort
of cool strong Flex that she's doing I'm
so mad I did a live video this morning
in my garage with no makeup on yeah so
did everyone else on Tick Tock uh what
the [__] the point here yeah so what I
said
was I I just I want people to just
understand what she's saying here she
goes
um I am
I was so mad
that I did a live video in my garage
with no makeup on okay
now first off you can make fun of her
appearance now I'll say what I didn't
say in the Tweet you can make fun of her
appearance and say actually that's what
you would throw makeup on this looks
like you all the time but no makeup on
uh you're a Hagrid Beast uh you're a
terrible bomber face
you're just a cardboard groping Trump
fan you're uh Kevin McCarthy cuck you
have no party nobody like Yeti your your
husband doesn't even like you your
children don't even like you Lauren
bobert doesn't like her Lauren bobert
doesn't even like you that's saying a
lot she loves to grow too look the point
is Marjorie Taylor green makes this 12
and a half minute rant
and she wants to [__] and moan about
how it's going to be the Democrats how
it's the the left how it's the woke
agenda that's causing the uh that that
is what ultimately caused her to be so
upset
so mad that she left DC she [__]
tucked tail and ran back to Georgia when
there was still time on the clock
this is called giving up
when it all is on the line This is
called abandoning your constituents
and not doing your job
this is what the Republican party is
they don't do their job they're not
serious people and they do not care
about anyone they actually are supposed
to represent well and speaking of that
the reason the other reason why this is
bone-headed is because she's trying to
skate
um
scrutiny here because she has a big war
with with a lot of trumpers out there
that she's not actually a trump
supporter anymore that she's a Kevin
McCarthy supporter which a lot of people
don't know this but Donald Trump owns
Kevin McCarthy he holds his balls in a
little
um Big Mac uh Sack or box Big Mac Box
down at Martin Lawrence a bit of a vice
you know right right but that's that's
the thing is that she is leaving
Washington DC I believe because she
doesn't want the scrutiny from someone
of how she would or wouldn't vote
because she's going to be pressured into
voting a certain way but you have to
also understand that all these
Republicans including Lauren bobert are
like oh my God why are these people why
are we leaving why are we leaving and
then they leave
right like what are we doing what are we
doing
should do the work and then the next
time you see them is they're back in
their home District
getting bitched at
by their constituents some of them are
like oh they'll take it at face value
and say oh it is the Democrats problem
it is the Democrats who didn't do it
[__]
the house has majority a slim majority
but the house has majority they are the
ones in control and they are stalling
they're not getting the impeachment
inquiry or at least the the results of
the impeachment inquiry they want
because there's no actual evidence that
Joe Biden did something and if he did
then [__] show us
we're tired of getting blue bald
if you've got actual [__] evidence
then show us God damn I've never been
blue balled so much in my goddamn life
if you're gonna juice the beetle don't
give us blue balls for crying out loud
[__] [__] in that thing and then just
stop Midway through oh intermission
gotta go home no you're out of here
you're out of here finish the job
speaking of what it is speaking of blue
balls there's no better blue baller than
Kevin speaker pretends speaker Kevin
McChicken
um here he is the winner of bonehead of
the week Kevin McCarthy and of course
boy out [__] yeah the obvious reason
why Kevin McCarthy is the the winner is
because he he can't do the simple
function of I know keeping the
government open he's got really two
choices here Gabe Sanchez he can either
work with Democrats and lose his
speakership or he can not work at all
which is what Republicans typically do
they don't govern and that he can just
shut the government down and [__] the
American bold [__] American
government [__] these job [__] what his
responsibilities are you know because
Trump wants it closed and he'll keep it
closed until Trump says it's closed so
my guess is I mean and I think I'm gonna
be right here is that he's gonna shut
the government down until Trump says
open it back up but here here is a slew
of Republicans who are not happy with
the bonehead of the week Kevin McCarthy
with all due respect to my conservative
colleagues let them go explain why they
don't support that it's completely
inexplicable
um and uh I think it's indefensible so
you know here we said so now we got to
go try to figure out how to move forward
but we had agreement in good faith with
people across the conference the
speaker's job be in Peril if he relies
on Democrats
it wouldn't be a good move but speaker
McCarthy relies on Democrats to pass a
continuing resolution uh I would call
the capital moving truck to his office
pretty soon because my expectation would
be he'd be out of the speaker's office
quite they'll probably be the one to
suggest you see a shutdown but uh if
that's where it's going that's where
it's going
bird [__] that we heard from earlier hey
can't stop school shootings and you
can't stop shutting down I mean it would
be like if I did my job it might help
yeah it is what it is it is what it is I
mean I'm not going to do my job I'm a
lazy piece of [__] I thought for a
moment I thought for a moment a little
bit just a little bit I was like us
representative burchett is going to
speak out in defense of why we should
not have a government shutdown he's like
well guess I'll just go back to my home
skilled children and safe and sound in
their home so they don't have to worry
about getting shot and I get my my pay
my benefits and my family are fully
covered so I don't have to worry about
that dumb [__] that you regular people
have to focus on
I think that's the face they make yeah
she speaks to make for Bona of the week
here's Kevin McCarthy saying he is too
busy not doing anything to let president
zielinski speak to a joint session
literally that's what he said did you
turn down the joint uh session of
Congress for zelinski president
zielinski asks for a joint session we
just didn't have time he's already given
a joint session so what we're doing for
um
for zielinski is exactly the same thing
that we did for the prime minister of
the UK the prime minister of Italy will
put in the bipartisan uh group of
members together no different than we
did with anybody else and yeah this is a
little busy week oh is it a funding
issue I don't know how it could be busy
you just you just left what are you
gonna say to him you're about to leave
well I think I think the best part is to
sit down
what is the plan for victory where are
we currently on the field the
accountability issues that a lot of
members have questions Victory from one
Victory from one you mean Oh you mean
you mean fighting the Russians
when I saw this clip yesterday it
reminded me of those moments when
someone's like hey are you you know like
do you want to come to my party and like
oh I'm sorry I'm totally busy that day
and they're like I didn't even say the
day or the time and you're like oh when
is it you're like oh April 10th you're
like oh yeah yeah that oh man that's
gonna be a busy day oh man look I got
all that stuff going on yeah but not
this year next year like yeah it's an
annual thing right right
[Laughter]
yeah [__] you know what if Republicans
would have just thought about hey you
know what we should do we should do our
job probably keep the government open
and I don't know do the thing that
Congress is supposed to do and like fund
them what's it called the government
yeah come September we wouldn't have to
[__] be rushing to try to figure out
why we're shutting the government down
and I want to give you an insight into
this Trump is ordering the government to
be shut down folks period period and how
you know this is Matt Getz is saying in
that prior clip Kevin McCarthy can't do
he can't do these two options he cannot
work with Democrats or we will vacate
his seat and he cannot keep the
government open with Republicans because
we're going to stop him the government
is being shut down because Trump is
ordering it to be shut down Kevin
McCarthy you are the bonehead of the
week this week but you are not the
speaker of the house you are pretending
me to speak in the house the actual
speaker house has your balls and a Big
Mac in a in a little Big Mac Box down at
Mar-A-Lago or bedminister wherever that
[__] fat [__] is right now but you
you sure are the bone of the week
because you can't even do your [__]
job and keep the government open you
piece of trash it's very very simple
just keep the lights on that's your job
[__] don't mess up keep the lights on
make sure everything is you know just a
bare minimum right bare minimum right
well he reached the bare minimum this
week and Kevin McCarthy McChicken is
bonehead of the week let's give him his
do
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh Kevin pretends speaker McChicken you
are the bonehead of the week and you are
a feckless [__] and you deserve all the
[__] that is coming to you my friend
good luck to you over the next six or
eight months as you're forced to act
like and still pretend that you're the
speaker while the government's closed
because your orange Mussolini Jesus
won't let you open it because he owns
you and he owns you from the very
beginning it is a reason why it took you
so long to become the speaker and until
you really realize that that you
actually have no power while you're the
speaker then you can just give it away
just give it away just do what you're
supposed to do and open the [__]
government because you don't have power
in the first place oh Kevin you piece of
[__] what a piece of you said it wasn't
even close you just ran out of the gate
right out of the gate didn't even get
didn't even get close no I mean he was
all the way over boom shakalaka boom
shakalaka well
that's been bone of the week stick
around we got a few announcements right
after this
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week I'm glad you got to
join us I I'm I'm not happy that you're
feeling under the weather I sound like I
sound like uh Trump
sniffing everything
right now it's it's not the best it is
the best sickness
oh I'm surprised he didn't make it on
bonehead of the week but he didn't he
didn't make it on bone of the week he
didn't you know who else could have been
on bonehead of the week if at the very
last minute Tucker Carlson having his
show on you know who else could have
been on bonehead of the week but I
didn't have his graphic in time who's
Rupert Murdoch oh my God there's so many
there's so many that could be honest or
Alpha cut or whatever yeah anything
dishonorable mention we could have a
hundred of them but we didn't have time
but I'm glad you're here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern lemon Central nine Pacific and
Gabe Sanchez's new live show what was
that live on Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursdays right directly after this show
so do not forget next week to stay tuned
for three full hours
of Tony and Gabe on Tuesdays Wednesdays
and Thursdays thanks for all your
support there we really do appreciate it
make sure you subscribe here at detoni
Michaels podcast go down in the link
below find Gabe Sanchez's patreon find
his YouTube link and find his link tree
and go follow his YouTube channel there
as well everyone have a great weekend
don't do anything I wouldn't do
uh we'll see you next week with more Bob
Menendez gold bars and cash with d
ude times same place on Monday Surf's Up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon